[Music]
brought to you by hulu time to have
great original shows and movies
what's up party people welcome to honest
trailer commentaries the show where we
talk about the video we made about the
movie that someone worked hard to make
and destroy it i'm cobra commander
filling in for spencer j gilbert joining
me is always daniel radford and lon
harris it's good to see you guys again
thanks for being here cobra commander
it's great to have you yeah i didn't
know we were going to have a celebrity
guest friend of the show cobra commander
you know i was in the neighborhood
well i'm in the valley yeah and once you
get into the valley you know it's like i
might as well spend the day
you were in the neighborhood of the room
joe starr uses to zoom and you orlando
might as well jump on there that's right
i'm over here with my bud
not a lot of people know you just start
grow up together you're talking really
close yeah yeah we're gonna crack open
some brewskis later this is not
this is a reboot so this is not joseph
gordon levitt under the hood folks
totally different
not a guy who was in an explosion and
none of that none of that look i'm gonna
level with you i'm not sure if i was
gonna do this bit as i'm just gonna talk
about the movie or i'm gonna pretend
that gi joe and cobra are real fandom
style irl baby yeah that's right and uh
and like react to it as like a
propaganda piece i don't know yet maybe
a little bit of both folks we're here to
talk about gi joe origin well no sorry
snake eyes
colon gi joe origins from the movie that
was made from the book
based on some film that was made based
on push by sapphire based on push by the
baroness so first of all uh i i think
it's very telling that uh none of us
really seem to remember the film albeit
having just watched it so general
thoughts and feelings to kick us off and
then we'll jump into watching
uh line you want to go first
uh yeah i don't what huh like because
it's i
look i get i get the okay we're gonna do
shared universe you start with some of
the characters and give us their corner
of the world and then we go bigger i get
that i get why you do that but it seems
weird like i think of gi joe it's like
sci-fi it's like military it's like kind
of futuristic it's like weapons and and
you know trucks and guns and all that
and so to start in this world that is
not just like ninja stuff but like in a
fantasy world like no sci-fi at all it's
like rocks from the gods that give you
powers and it's like a totally different
franchise i don't get how this is
gearing us up for gi joe at all it seems
not even remotely related to gi joe yeah
and like the fight scenes especially
like the fight scene in the beginning
was dope and i got to a point where i
was like this is a little long like this
fight scene like by the time we have uh
swords that can penetrate a truck um i
was like this is getting a little too
long and then i started to realize like
oh that might be
like we're not gonna get much more of
this like i thought there would be more
of them no the trump scene is really
weird
because there's two guys sitting in a
truck and they have swords that can
easily like through butter go through a
truck and yet they they seem incapable
of stabbing the two like if there was a
guy sitting in a truck right next to you
just stab him like that
it's the refraction of they're like
they seem to have a lot of trouble
figuring out where their sword is going
to go once it goes inside the truck and
it's like this is not this is just
physics like just
get me in and on in there they're 10
feet away i don't know it's like yeah
they managed to do the like uh blaster
that doesn't hit but they managed to do
it with not with something it would be
like stormtroopers couldn't kill you if
they were right next to you with a sword
like well now come on now come on guys
yeah burn your
pay
uh no no match for my vipers uh i agree
uh i thought the movie was very just
like strange you know i i come from uh
sorry i'm gonna blur let's blur the
lines of the [ __ ] i grew up with the
comics with like the larry hammer giajo
comics those comics loved them some
ninja stuff
uh
but like then you get into like glow
the movie got into like blowing rocks
and like it was weird but then they were
also trying to do like a classic
like japanese yakuza
uh versus the police like the departed
type
a lot of different weird levels right
because i remember the cartoons and
there was a lot of ninja stuff there but
they still had like gadgets it still
felt like ninja stuff in a gi joe world
and this feels like ninja stuff in a
weird ninja stuff world that has nothing
to do with judges except then scarlett
shows up and they're like she's with the
gi joes don't worry about it it's on the
poster we we had we had like yeah
well i think you know and just as like a
we'll get into it as we watch the
trailer and comment but yeah especially
as a franchise restarter i'm the
franchise starter that's my favorite
prodigy song
um
uh cobra commander loves the prodigy uh
yeah it just felt like a weird nothing
film to kick off a big franchise to
compete with it's also we touched on it
a bit like the considering it is a ninja
film about ninjas not a lot
and there are some people in it who have
been in great martial arts films not a
lot of great martial arts action in this
film it kind of cuts
away a lot and you kind of don't get a
lot of like just just fight scenes which
is as the great jeff goldblum once said
there will be ninja fights in your ninja
fighting movie right
but there wasn't let's let's this is
let's roll the honest trailer
for snake eyes colon gi joe origins
oh i can't hear it someone tell the
televipers
you know snake eyes as a voiceless
masked ninja now get ready to see a
whole new side of him
voiced i didn't sign up for this
fazed and very bad at ninja stuff
but did you know he was also a dick
stop sucker punching women in the face
snake eyes i'm trying to like you
stop
fast and furious presents gi joe begins
snake eyes origins from the book of saul
don't take me back
right out the gate that's pause i mean
look if all a character has going for it
is the mystique that when we grew up
with it he was a mysterious badass that
was dope at everything
if your first question approaching this
project is what if he wasn't any of
those things that's a bad question to
ask it's
weird to say look you gotta you're gonna
cast a celebrity we're gonna see his
face he's gonna say a few lines fine
okay i i get i get why you feel like you
need to do that with your main character
i guess although there have been cool
movies that don't do that but okay fair
enough i guess but the making him not a
very good ninja and then not even
integrating like ninja training or going
to ninja school into the movie like all
of his we talk about this in the trailer
all of his training is like purely
mental it's like overcome your fear or
like stop lying to all of us about who
you are but it's never just like here's
how you do this roundhouse kick which is
like a really important part of being a
ninja oh my god it reminds me of a
combination of both mortal kombats where
we get the guy who like is kind of a
sucky fighter and then he winds up being
like the one in the new mortal kombat
spoilers and then uh you get the version
where it's like face your fear
use the element which brings life like
oh like all of those like weird
i get that you got to do that mystical
spiritual side of it that helps the
drama whatever but you also have to do
the part where they just like do the
punches like blue belt stuff because
otherwise it's just not believable like
nobody ever like i don't think there's
one ninja lesson in this whole movie
that is set at a ninja school but get
but it it's important to note that a man
named snake eyes has to look a snake
in the eyes
hey let's just get into that now
there's a lot of snake in here
on the good guys side of things
for a franchise where the bad guys a
snake
it's something i haven't thought about
that growing up that his name is snake
eyes that he's fighting cobra they
should be on my side they even get you
an expert jones can have croc master
i'll do a trade
but it's the funny thing is in this
movie
it's not even because of snakes it's the
dice so the snakes are just purely
extraneous like none of the snake
imagery he's not a snake guy he's a dice
guy as soon as i saw the dice i was
immediately like oh
what if andrew dice clay had been in the
pit
yeah the only way to pass the third
challenge you gotta take out the dice
man
oh that's great hickory dickory dock oh
yeah that's the second challenge is
smoking a cigarette around your head
well he's already got the punching women
uh the the misogyny cupboard so yeah
yeah
punching jinx in the face was that jinx
they never called her jinx i wasn't sure
she did she didn't earn her code name by
the end of the movie like storm shadow
like the shadow before a storm
continue so that spencer doesn't get mad
that i made this two hours long don't
care about the gi joe movies you're not
alone no one does not even the actors
detail attention
but when the studio who placed last at
the box office for seven years
because after two prequels setting up a
big joe versus cobra showdown paramount
is rolling the dice with another prequel
i swear this whole studio is dangling by
a tom cruise fingertip
inner frame is known for its huge cast
of high-tech super soldiers focus on one
goon trying to [ __ ] his way through
ninja school but in the grand tradition
of solo the phantom menace and wolverine
origins learn how the character you love
used to suck back in the day he's a liar
he worked
you earned his trust he's a thief i was
hoping you wouldn't do that he's a
traitor to the people who welcomed him
his family we could have been brothers
he's kind of slow
it's only because his dad used to work
there your father was one of us
he was a joe
knowing the right people is half the
battle
[Music]
i'm not one to be beholden to cannon
okay
like if you change something i'm not
gonna be a little crybaby about it all
right i'm not gonna go back to cobra
island and be like uh
they ruined my childhood
but
they're gonna change something like do
it better like the
the whole thing
with storm shadow and snake eyes and i i
don't know it's been a while since i was
11. so hang on i might get some of this
wrong but if i remember correctly
um
someone kills either the hard master or
the blind master one of the two
maybe the blind master
and snake ass thinks storm shadow did it
and storm shadow thinks hey guys did it
i believe it's the hard master in the
original movies because rizza is the
living blind
originally as children in an extended
series
just stop the movie where they've been
in ninja school together for a long time
they're best pals
and then someone kills the blind master
spoiler alert it's zartan
yes
this voice is so hard to do
someone else talk for a minute yeah it's
it's it's just
like right we that's the weirdest thing
about this whole decision to do this
movie is that the previous gi joe movies
already did the snake storm shadow
backstory we've seen it now three times
and it's always variations on the same
thing they they were best friends
brothers and then something happened
that drove them apart but they're wrong
about it and they just yeah their bad
lack of communication which i guess if
you're a ninja that doesn't speak is
gonna happen
i just know you're gonna have
miscommunications with old friends that
don't get resolved everything was so
surface like
i would have
i don't know man like
you know
make them know each other for a while so
that
when he finds out storm shadow's a spy
in the yakuza he's like oh well he's
also my buddy right like
like it's like oh i'm lying to him but
you just lied to him like last week you
know
you haven't been a double agent your
whole life it's one of those
cobra plots it's one of those plots that
one line of dialogue could resolve the
whole thing right all henry golding
needs to do and a bunch of points of
this movie is to go like hey i haven't
been totally honest with you all this
guy
he was from netflix's geary girihaji
great show recommended it he told me to
come over here and try to steal your gem
i feel bad i'm not gonna do it
but he knows who killed my dad can we go
get him and find out who did it they'd
all go great yeah sure thanks for
watching
i was watching this film with my spouse
mrs coburn commander
and she was like
man if only he was also friends with an
elite ring of ninja spies
i could maybe do a little research into
who killed his dad that's what i mean
it's just like just say your problem out
there they're all the entire movie
they're all standing in a circle around
i'm like just tell uh just tell us and
then he's gonna come clean yeah go ahead
danielle no i'm just gonna say if you're
gonna give him a voice then he should
probably use it to move the plot forward
or else there's no point plus we also
get into this but why are you making him
speak in an american accent when his
voice is so cool anyway just yeah just
let let british people be british they
sound neat
i agree
no but like and then the moment when
he's finally gonna use his voice to come
clean
instead of saying all that stuff you
guys said he just says
i want to kill the guy that killed my
dad and everyone's like and it's and
then tommy oh for one thing come on
tommy mommy tommy yeah
yeah tommy yeah
somebody that lives in a dojo castle in
the middle of tokyo full of mystical
snakes was like i'm naming this kid this
kid tommy okay i love the pinball wizard
musical i'm naming him tommy tommy ninja
but then he's like
sorry about the snakes guys
but i'm mad at the guy that killed my
dad and tommy's like
like he reacts yeah like like he came
clean about being a spy but he's just
like you do also have to love
the confidence of all right this third
challenge if you're not totally honest
with us you will die we're gonna throw
you in this pit something's gonna happen
and to just be like i'm a really good
liar like i could this no this is no
problem for me like he's just a hundred
percent confidence that he can pull this
off against an entire team of like
ancient ninja
plus if the whole movie's about this
brotherhood slash maybe this uh
burdening love interest about this guy
who really wants to make out with henry
golden because i mean let's face it look
at him look at the man yeah he should be
the one that goes in the hole
not jinx
yeah this should be him and then henry
golding has to be like i'm a spy and
then he's like oh my god i jumped in the
snakes just anyway
resume why do you think they have to
feed those snakes they're huge so much
food that's like they're yeah what's the
money i'm keeping three massive anaconda
if you don't politely ask for the bowl
you get fed
[Laughter]
a man is lost and wandering as his
american accent
ghost for so long my father's murdered
when i was a kid he must infiltrate the
secretive arashika ninja clan so
secretive even they don't know what they
actually do a little of this
they're led by tommy a man with every
reason to distrust this complete
stranger with no past but when you have
a face like henry golding doers just
seem to slide open to you even the doors
to the lantern warehouse where you hide
your magic ninja egg must resist his
charming face dude
a dick
before they can make this it's a
rashikagi official snake eyes will have
to pass three deadly ninja tests test
one ask nicely for a bowl request that
you accept my ball in exchange for yours
test two have a bad dream this is more
than a test you pass or fail it is a
mirror to reveal your weakness and test
do not fight a giant snake i repeat do
not fight the snake if you want to pass
they never harm those who are pure of
heart which means you can graduate from
this ninja academy without doing any
martial arts see this is why you just
can't find a good ninja these days place
is a total mcdojo i heard they hand out
orange belts just for signing up
you're not gonna make them do kata
like a little a little two-step sparring
at least come on we not only don't ever
see them train an actual ninja but we
don't ever find out how they got all
their money or what they do or like i
think we get zero information on what
the arashikage are just you really
really want to join them
like for real like it's worth going into
this pit with the snakes
yeah and then you join what do you do
all day stand around
carry lanterns you use that nifty
computer that just shows you pictures of
things that are happening in other
scenes where you can also see where
they're happening yeah it's just like
you got to give us one scene where we
get a sense of like what's the
day-to-day like what are they doing like
are they a criminal organization are
they a non-profit like what are they
are they opening this place for tours
like what is it danielle what do they do
they're just a clan you can't just be a
clan that's not a thing i don't know i
like the idea that they're a non-profit
uh you know
they're just uh uh what they do is they
make those bowls
[Laughter]
and then they and then they sell the
bowls and then that's why they have so
many like the bowl ceremony is just them
practicing for how you know would you
like to take this bowl it is 1999. yeah
hard master just goes around to high
schools around the country it gives
little presentations and then sells the
bulls yeah yeah 12 of proceeds go to
charities the rest goes to feeding the
giants
and for placing those lanterns you know
one of those lanterns burns out like
every other day there's some low-level
ninja that's constantly replacing
lanterns that guy's got a bad job yeah
lantern guy and i also think i'm
cleaning like the helmet room is also
just like oh my god
nothing but helmets and suits of armor
jeez
video onward thrill had a cast of actors
who are so badass you could just show a
wide shot of them fighting and it would
be brad to watch featuring andrew koji a
man who crushed a role bruce lee wrote
for himself
humanly fast physical talent
kenji tonight the fight coordinator for
some of japan's best modern samurai
films and hand all these action figures
over to the legendary martial arts
director robert schwenke who's robert
schwenke let's see a couple of divergent
movies red r.i.p.d
uh oh right well in that case abandon
all hope because no matter how good
these people may be in other films
they'll get the nauseating shaky cam
treatment usually reserved for liam
neeson hopping offense
[Applause]
[Music]
shaking the camera to make action more
exciting is like shaking a book to make
the words more exciting you want shaky
cam shake your head in front of the
screen
so now that you definitely don't have to
look
if you want to make a big hollywood
ninja movie i feel like step one is
who's who's a really great action
director like am i crazy
like honestly i like yes like no you're
not crazy kobe creditor yes obviously
you should get like a great action
director but in some of these cases it's
almost like less would be more like
there are some of these scenes where
literally just set the camera up and let
these
fight coordinators and choreographers
and martial artists like do their thing
like they're definitely some of these
fights that would have just been better
film them like just don't even bother
setting up like just just have a guy
with a camera and like show us what
happens because a lot of the time
they're doing cool stuff we just can't
see what it is because we're constantly
cutting to different perspectives and
yeah i mean this this you know just to
use the stuff that we reference in here
by the way watch warrior on hbo max it's
the best show um
joe and i agree
um
but like the night comes for us there's
fights in that that are like 15 minutes
long and there's like six cuts right
that's a review yeah
come on
but and also like again
you got to assume that everyone's goal
with all these ips is beat marvel
you gotta do like respect to the
director of ripd
but
i don't know marvel's like hey who are
all these cool hot new directors let's
let's give them a character to direct
wouldn't you want to do the same thing
yeah it's it's it's it's odd that the
guy who did ripd and like the later
divergence would even like land a
property of this size like hasbro like
this is what they've got this is their
big thing like
it feels like someone really depressed
is calling the shots at paramount like
it probably won't work anyway well maybe
nothing really matters brian robbins
will come in and be more excited maybe
that's that starts starting today just
seems like a bummer that's all i'm
saying like you'd think they'd be stoked
to do a big budget ninja movie but
instead they were like meh what's the
point
marvel's going to steamroll
yeah and yeah all the gi joe movies
they've all there's three of them now
and they've all kind of felt that way
where it's just like you're not treating
this like the property that it is which
is internationally recognizable and
iconic and like
they're always it feels like they're
afraid to do gi joe and like no just do
classic gi joe like it starts joe's
already a thing you've got a bunch of
the guys the girls they're their
characters they're ready to go cobra
does some stuff there's a mission like
why don't we just get a conventional gi
joe movie after three now doing weird
setup stuff yeah we've proven that
people like bright colorful stuff so
like why can't we just make it like that
we've
where you introduce a bunch of vehicles
and new weapons and all the classic
characters are all there you're not like
setting it up that one day they'll show
up but like i don't get it and i agree
with both of you i feel like of all of
these like childhood ips like this one
it's the least storytelling we're like
explaining easy
those guys are soldiers
those guys are snake themed soldiers
they don't like each other
that's kind of it that's it i it was the
same thing like x-men we used to every
time we would do a new honest trailer i
would have this rant where it's like why
are they always like they just broke up
or they're just about to form we never
just get like
the x-men where it's like professor x
gets a call from the president it's like
right away mr president then they go in
the exit they like fight some other
mutants like that's it's a it's a real
wang tease yeah that's all x-men stories
like why don't just do that
yeah that's like what i want to see yeah
that's the fun part i don't care about
them forming the x-men like that i
assume that happened if there's an x-men
same with this just like give me a line
of cobras and a lighter joe shooting
point blank range lasers that miss each
other right and then after 90 minutes i
yell retreat
box up is gold yeah yeah
you don't need any backstory at all for
like nope these are the good guys those
are the terrorists and they're shooting
each other that's it plus
uh okay video on one now that you
definitely don't have to brave an actual
theater to see it get ready to hang in
the group chat call half watching the
latest hollywood prequel that cares as
little as possible about gi joes and
cobra as you legally can when gi joe is
on the poster major herder is with the
jaws
what
they're the good guys oh well i guess
they can do better with snake eyes too
ninjutsu boogaloo there's still so many
gi joe ninjas to pick from let's see you
got dojo bonsai ah
nunchuck
okay wait maybe the bad guys were cooler
that's either slice
and uh
dice
yeah let's just not do this actually
starring ah snake temple
a couple of real sea listeners
dice
this snake eyes his arch nemesis would
be dice
no
yes yeah oh my god you're right this is
chief rival that's what we're obviously
setting up in part two dice clearly
needed to be in this movie but it's
gonna be a sentient pair of dice it's
not gonna be a guy
actually have to named
dice
voiced by someone very famous
beyonce i think i mean today as the
voice of the dice
anyway i've been i've probably been
waiting since the fifth grade to make a
joke about slice and dice
was it everything you hoped it would be
it felt pretty good you're not gonna die
oh pretty good
all right sorry let's keep onward
snake snake
[Applause]
hard masturbating
in the airport with the stick things the
aristocrats my anacondas don't want none
if you got pure heart son and
[Music]
oh no one police car got honor and or
clarity
if you want a real movie about ninja's
fighting cobra watch cobra versus
he will not accept your challenge
he will
he can't refuse me when he receives the
ninja challenge card
and you've got to defeat me first
sure
[Music]
it's on youtube you're welcome
man i tell you guys what little inside
baseball i read the script
and i slapped spencer
and i said hey man
we've been friends for a long time
i've never asked you for anything
i'm calling in the favor
kevin's commented he found a version
called cobra against
i've only ever heard of this film as
cobra versus ninja yeah
yeah man
i i could talk for several hours about
the films of godfrey ho
of course do some research and learn
about uh the ed wood of of hong kong
cinema if you will uh the glorious
filmmaker
ninja terminator uh i was talking about
recently where that one has a guy
challenged to a ninja tournament by like
a little toy robot that comes to his
house
explodes that's another cloudfree ho
absolute classic that's what happens
with the amazon drones that's what's
next oh no it's just ninja challenge
cards left and right
yeah delivered by prime a lot a lot of
these movies a lot of gun real movies
are they're less about the fights
themselves they're more about the very
elaborate challenges that ninjas are
constantly issuing there's like it's
like a john wick underworld of ninjas
constantly challenging other ninjas for
ninja supremacy you know look you two i
i i love you guys that i miss you
and uh
when i when i when i walked away to do
the dnd beyond job there was it just
felt like something was unfinished
and it was getting this joke into it
now i feel like i can go do d d beyond
with a pure heart and the snakes won't
eat me now you're ready yeah yeah you're
ready to move on to the next i'm gonna
do the call to action or whatever and
then we can uh
do deleted scenes hey
thanks so much for watching
unless you're sopento then what are you
doing you've got an organization to run
subscribe to our channels for videos
every day hit that like and hit that
bell
yeah
uh for more piffy comments such as
ninja rocks in my day we just used
weather dominators that's a machine that
dominates the weather yeah it doesn't
doesn't control it just dominates it
dominates it
um just makes it feel low
we gotta talk about sub-zero
temperatures
finish him
let's watch these deleted scenes and
we'll get some audience questions and if
you got more questions
tell ryan about him in chat
you're my sub hero
nice to see you
double agent dragon beverly hills ninja
andrew dice lay
stormy clan
watch warrior now on hbo max
tommy the white ranger paw
open up a clan a whip ass
now you beat me
does anyone gonna tell him this kimono
doesn't match the others no tosin why
guy
hard out here for a master
uh-huh he said hard
yeah he's a master
raid detention he's really good at it
nice to meet you agent smith
m.i.a joe
the past and the furious tokyo whiffed
and dice hard
so you have three giant anacondas in
your control but you don't use them to
protect your most sacred item instead
you put it in a shed that requires your
own blood to enter you're just asking
for you and your family to get murdered
you guys are terrible at this just turn
the place into an airbnb instead
i agreed great i also pitched
bullshitto as a title and spencer was
like you get bulshito or you get cobra
versus ninja
i had to pick we got some hey hey gang
we got some questions hey
from our viewers
pretzel asks aside from knowing
what is half the battle for you to
succeed
i guess what's the other half right
nowing is half the battle i would say uh
yes sci-fi weapons that's the other half
of the battle having the best laser
games
uh yeah definitely uh knowing ninja
stuff uh sounds like a very pretty
important part of the battle
actually bothering to take the time to
learn the ninja stuff rather than just
put yourself in the mental space to do
ninja stuff yeah important
important i know an often overlooked
part of the ninja training process yeah
no i would say uh proper vocal warm-ups
before you do this first
[Laughter]
support
one quarter canadian asks how long can
he do that voice without his throat
hurting the answer was 30 seconds
you could have just done the intro like
that and then become joe starr i don't
think any of us are committing to the
bit lord
i would never forgive myself
um let's see here uh evan also asks uh
if you could make any character totally
silent and faceless in a film or show
who would it be i mean you could have
done it with this guy honestly he could
have not said a word
yeah we really didn't need to hear all
that much from him it would have been
would have been fine yeah it would have
been fine
um
see now i'm actually excited for the
character but i would say during most of
the avengers i could deal with like a
hawkeye that didn't talk or have a face
no top guy
yeah i can't be okay with that again i i
really it feels like it wouldn't have
even made that big
no of course now i'm excited for the
show so i wouldn't want it now but
they're definitely like three days ago i
would have been like yeah just make that
guy silent and faceless i would have
liked a hawk i think where he's he's
he's faceless and he just like makes
noises but like black widow's the only
one that can understand him like a han
chewie thing
oh i like that
yeah where he was like what's that oh we
do have to stop and get some schwein
hawkeye is right
yeah
i would um i wouldn't mind a batman
movie where he never talked when he was
batman
i feel like there's a lot of pressure on
actress to nail the bat voice
that's always the moment where you're
like uh oh like the first time a batman
actor was like oh batman then you're
like okay
and we're gonna do this for two hours
it's also it would be like more
intimidating like he's supposed to be
this like
monster you know like the way they talk
about him like that he's like not even
human but then he's just like well hey
commissioner like wait what uh just
killing the mystique yeah
james bunt asks if back in the day
michael bay oh james did you need to
write a poem you did
if back in the day michael bay had been
given g.i joe to play
rather than the transformers would its
fate have been different um
i mean
michael bay films are basically an
eight-year-old like cranking like
slamming toys together
so i
i dare could he have done a good [ __ ]
i mean the jingoism is there my my main
hang up with the transformers movies is
that i don't like the way he makes the
transformers look and like
it doesn't it doesn't feel like their
faces are all weird and mushy and it's
hard to follow who's talking and like so
i feel like getting rid of that and
letting him just focus on people
fighting other people probably would
have been a big improvement and it's
more evenly matched like that's the
problem you get to the end of the
transformers films and it's like well
obviously the army of massive robots
with high-tech weapons are going to beat
like
tyrese with a gun
so like at the end of gi joe cobra
movies would be more evenly matched like
this army versus that arc
yeah because i just i just think it
would be more fun like i think that it
would be a lot more fun to watch him do
like a gi joe movie like you know um i
think maybe the quips would land um no
racist robots which is always a big plus
for me yeah so just racist vipers just
raise the snipers um but yeah so i think
that it would be like way more fun for
him to do something like this plus like
he's like i it's so hard to see so much
of the action in transformers when it
seems really easy to me that the answer
is just giant robot fighting giant robot
um but i like to believe it would be
better with something like this
we still have to deal with all of his
michael bay jokes though yeah i mean i
look at you know like all the navy seal
stuff in the rock that stuff's cool yeah
and i guess you know i could see him do
you remember in the old gi joe the
cartoon movie where like the opening
credits is like cobra attacking the
statue of liberty for no reason yes yes
that's what i'm saying like
these movies should just be that it's
like every movie cobra commander has
another crazy plan to like blow up the
hoover dam or turn the statue of liberty
into a statue of him and like the joe's
have to stop him like that's all we want
it doesn't they're overthinking it to
like the hundredth degree
hey guys this is a fun one
jeffrey overton says other than jujitsu
good taste jeffrey what martial arts
movies would you recommend
we did an sju about this the other day
but um
uh i'm sure man it's a it's a good
question the i'll say that the 90s hong
kong films that got me into martial arts
and kung fu movies are still the ones
that hold a special place in my heart so
stuff like rumble in the bronx or iron
monkey or super cop like that whole era
when they when like mirror max started
bringing those hong kong movies out into
us theaters under different titles uh i
i love all that stuff and obviously
jackie chan's police story the the first
two police story movies which kind of
start kick-started that whole trend uh
and i believe supercop is in fact one of
the later police story sequels if i'm
not mistaken uh those are those are
amazing those are classics if if you
want something recent uh the swordsman
from 2020 that's pretty good uh dude
that played the hard master uh uh joe oh
no no no no no no he's not joke no joe
tolston's not the hot mess yeah no joe
tulsa was sub-zero right
yeah he was sub-zero thank you and he's
the he's been also in warrior right um
yeah heart master is eco oase from the
raid and
we mentioned a few others uh uh with him
as well the knight comes for us headshot
with him which is freaking amazing
danielle that he picks i mean obviously
who's the master obviously that's good
that's always going to be my pick
because because it is it's like it's fun
and it's silly and it's really like an
homage um and i think if you go into it
with like thinking of it like that where
it's really like a love letter to the
black community's um absolute adoration
of like old martial arts films if you go
and and there's music um
so if you go into it like looking at it
like that um but it is this like love
letter to these movies it's wonderful
no absolutely very very well said both
of you um
let's see here uh
uh raynor reynolds city update channel
asks that's a interesting name was that
your birth name
um question for cobra commander which is
better the film cobra or commando oh
[ __ ] wow tough call on that one honestly
wow
it really is um
maybe for
for pure spectacle of action
commando but if you really just want
swag and flavor you can't beat cobra
no one in commando takes a slice of
pizza uses a scissors to cut off just a
tip and then he eats that part of the
pizza slice
that's never happened in any movie other
than cobra that i've ever seen
well hey crew this has been a fun
reunion any closing thoughts on uh i'm
getting the light um
[Laughter]
any any from one of the crimson gods
any closing thoughts on snake eyes
poland gi joe origins
um i hope that this does not wreck uh
but this doesn't wind up being like a
ding against henry's career because i do
think that he's like a very promising
young actor um and so i hope this isn't
one of those things where it's like well
it tanked because of him it's like no it
tanked for like a lot of reasons
i just yeah i mean i hope i hope they
these these studios and these companies
start getting this lesson that like
the
the like making it look like a ninja
world isn't enough and people the action
has to match the setting or it's not
going to play like people aren't going
to be so easily fooled uh and we
seem to keep making this this mistake
where these movies kind of have the
right setting but then don't have the
action scenes that aren't compelling and
it's like well that's never going to
play yeah it's it's frustrating danielle
you make a great and i you know not to
get all serious but i look [ __ ]
ridiculous
but like
raghu kohli was you know that video went
around you know where he was making that
point where it was like if if this movie
flops they're not going to be like oh
it's a bad movie they're going to be
like oh cause no one wanted to go see
raul coley in a movie and they so the
same like i hope that this doesn't like
you know
you paired all these all-stars you know
smash mouth song level all-stars
with an i mean kind of a dud of a
director and you
you know what can they do
yeah so hopefully this doesn't dull the
stars of uh of these people uh
at least in the you know all of these
guys are fine internationally the rest
of the world seems to be
uh perfectly okay to uh to give these
folks starring vehicles even though they
they might be in a bad g.i joe movie in
america but hopefully hollywood
continues to go oh these are dope people
and that we should continue to lift up
and work with
for sure
for
sure you guys hey
next week there's guess what's gonna
happen next week
i mean i know
another honest trailer
we're going to make we're going to make
another one of these thing can you
believe it
i can't believe it
let's see here what's a good clue
um
uh
uh it's uh it's gonna be a real trip
yeah uh it has a spiritual sister
starring cuba gooding jr i think i don't
know
nope it doesn't no
no is cuba in that
it's cuban who's in boat trip
uh who is in boat trip i thought that
cuba wasn't nice maybe he is you might
think it's a boat trip you're right it
is it's it's it's him in horatio sands
that's right i couldn't remember which
snl guy was that you're right you're
right
it's not 2002's boat trip that's not
next week's honest trailer folks ah but
what if it was
my victory complete
hey danielle hey lon
hey will on the ones and twos it was
good to visit with you guys ryan nikolai
what a great reunion so nice to see all
of you please join us next week when we
talk about the honest trailer for 2002's
boat trip
goodbye everyone
this episode was brought to you by who
[Music]
you